die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hallweg guten Abend und willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch dabei für den
Sport einen schönen guten Abend auch von
mir schauen wir auf die Nachrichten
Themen des
Tages Mission klimaclub in Dubai Kanzler
Scholz bringt bei der Weltklimakonferenz
eine Gruppe mit ambitionierten Ländern
an den
Start Feuerpause in nost beendet nach
einer Woche Ruhe sind die Kämpfe
zwischen Israel und der
Terrororganisation Hamas wieder
aufgeflammt und in der Gesamtwertung
vorn Biathletin Franziska Preu sprintet
in Östersund auf Rang 4 und übernimmt
damit die Führung im
Weltcup es sei noch nicht zu spät den
Zusammenbruch und das Verbrennen der
Erde zu verhindern so der Appell von un
Generalsekretär guterisch auf der
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai heute und
morgen sind dort diejenigen die zu einer
entscheidenden Wende Beitrag könten 170
Staats und Regierungschefs aus der
ganzen Welt auch der Bundeskanzler ist
dabei nur nicht auf diesem Foto weil er
erst danach ankam Mark
Hugo statsschuss in Dubai für den
klimaclub der Bundeskanzler hat ihn
mitgegründet der Club ein Bündnis aus
inzwischen 36 Industrie und
Entwicklungsländern gemeinsam wollen sie
die Wende vor allem für die
Schwerindustrie die sich noch schwer tut
klimafreundlich zu werden deshalb müssen
wir insbesondere für die Perspektiven
der Industrie und der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung sicherstellen dass wir
gleiche Maßstäbe haben ein Beispiel wie
internationaler Klimaschutz immer
konkreter werden kann sagen Beobachter
bei dieser Kop kommt es eben drauf an
auch dass wir wirklich Maßnahmen sehen
auch in verschiedenen Sektoren und das
ist jetzt eben eine Initiative von
einzelnen Ländern für den
Industriesektor da etwas voranzubringen
am Ende muss man das daran messen was
wirklich passiert aber es ist ein guter
Start hier auch den Industriesektor in
den Blick zu nehmen noch aber steigt der
weltweite
Treibhausgasausstoß ebenso wie die
Temperaturen um inzwischen schon 1,1° im
Vergleich zur Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts
mehr als 100 Regierungschefs und
Staatsoberhäupter kamen in Dubai schon
am Vormittag zusammen nicht weniger als
die entscheidende klimaschutzwende
wollen Sie hier schaffen am Ende der Kop
mus fordert der UNO Generalsekretär vor
allem eines stehen das Aus für kohleöl
und
Gas tig das 1,5 Limit halten wir nur
wenn wir endgültig aufhören fossile
Kraftstoffe zu verbrennen nicht
reduzieren nicht mindern aussteigen mit
einem klaren
Zeitplan morgen wird der Bundeskanzler
vor dem konferenzplenum reden dann wird
verhandelt Ergebnisse soll es in rund
zwei Wochen
geben Daniel Pen begleitet den Kanzler
Daniel zu Hause steht Olaf Scholz massiv
unter Druck wie schlägt er sich bislang
in
Dubai und er gibt sich unbeeindruckt von
der Lage zu Hause wie auch von der
Tatsache dass hier ja sowohl Deutschland
als auch die Welt insgesamt noch weit
weg ist von den Klimazielen die man sich
einst gesetzt hat das ganze erinnert
hier bildlich gesprochen an so eine Art
riesiges Schneckenrennen bei dem
Deutschland sehr wohl ambitioniert vorne
dabei ist das schon allerdings wieder
mit der Geschwindigkeit die man sich
selbst mal von sich selbst gewünscht
hatte und sich auch selbst verordnet
hatte noch ist es so dass die anderen
noch größeren noch wichtigeren Player
wie etwa China mit gleicher
Geschwindigkeit unterwegs werden sind
noch viel langsamer und zum Teil sogar
in die entgegengesetzte Richtung
unterwegs der Kanzler versucht trotzdem
an den Stellschrauben zu drehen die ihm
zur Verfügung stehen klimaclub z.B aber
hierbei wie auch bei allen anderen
Maßnahmen muss man eben erstmal sehen
wie wirkungsvoll das Ganze am Ende
wirklich sein wird zumal auch hier die
Geldfrage über allem schwebt der unklare
Haushalt in Deutschland führt dazu dass
zus sagen aus Deutschland hier erstmal
zumindest formell unter Vorbehalt stehen
allerdings hat der Kanzler eben betont
dass die Gelder die man hier zuagt auch
tatsächlich gezahlt werden die unklare
Finanzlage führt allings auch dazu dass
der Kanzler schon früher abreisen wird
morgen Mittag nämlich schon na dann
gerade mal 19 Stunden hier in Dubai
Daniel Pen live aus Dubai vielen Dank
jedes Jahr eine Klimakonferenz warum
diese Treffen so wichtig sind damit
beschäftigt sich ZDF heute live zu sehen
um 19:30 Uhr in der heute App und in
Social Media
Kanälen die Waffenruhe im Gazastreifen
ist vorbei und Israel und die Hamas
beschuldigen sich gegenseitig dafür vor
allem im Süden greift Israel jetzt
massiv an um die Zahl der zivilen Opfer
möglichst gering zu halten setzt die
israelische Armee auf eine neue
Strategie auf Arabisch wurde eine Karte
veröffentlicht die den Gazastreifen in
kleine Planquadrate einteilt jeder
Palästinenser solle ablesen wo er sich
befind und werde informiert wenn in
seinem Sektor Gefechte drohen über die
neue Gewalt luten
leinhus raketenalarm der Krieg ist
zurück Hamas Raketen auf Israel wenige
Minuten vor Ablauf der Feuerpause israel
reagiert mit aller Härte schickt Panzer
Kampfflugzeuge und
Bomben le hat die ham entschieden die
Feuerpause zu beenden sie ist nicht
bereititte Frau
freiulassen und sie greift mit Raketen
an nun wird die Hamas die Mutter aller
Schläge zu spüren
bekommen viele Bomben trafen heute Orte
wie kanunis wohin bereits 100taus aus
nordgasa geflüchtet sind israelische
Flugblätter fordern die Menschen auf
noch weiter in den Süden nach Raffa zu
gehen wir waren zu Hause und hörten
gerade die Nachrichten als die Bomben
fielen und unser Haus
zerstörten
wir sind müde ständig werden wir
bombardiert wie sollen wir es in dieser
gefährlichen Lage schaffen bis nach Rafa
zu
kommen sie singen sich Mut zu auf dem
Platz der Geiseln in telaviv viele
Wochen ein Ort der Hoffnung für die
Familien und Freunde der
entführten sein Bruder ist unter den
Geiseln lange hat er für Verhandlungen
demonstriert jetzt ist om
zerissen sie wird das beste tun und
danach zu Verhandlungen über
Freilassungen
zurückkehren als vorerst letzte
ramasgeiseln haben acht Frauen und
Teenager es vergangene Nacht
rausgeschafft aus dem gaserstreifen
136 sollen noch Gefangene der
Terroristen
sein Michael Bewerung in telaviv die
Hoffnung war dass die Feuerpause länger
hält und dass auch weitere Geiseln
freikommen warum hat es nicht
geklappt also von den ursprünglich mal
etwa 250 Geiseln sind nach offiziellen
Angaben noch 136 in Geiselhaft das sind
vor allem Männer aber auch 20 Frauen und
zwei Kinder wobei die beiden Kinder und
ihre Mutter möglicherweise nicht mehr am
Leben sind
es gab dann Streit wie die Frauen und
die älteren Geiseln zu behandeln sind
welchen Status haben sie sind es
Soldatinnen oder Zivilisten aus in der
Logik der Hamas haben Soldatinnen einen
höheren verhandlungswert trotz dieses
Scheiterns würde ich ein weiteres
geiselabkommen nicht ausschließen zu
einem zum einen ist das Prozedere
eingeübt wie es von statten gehen könnte
zum anderen werden beide Parteien im
Verlauf der weiteren Kämpfen kämpfe
weiter unter Druck geraten die Hamas
militärisch und die israelische
Regierung innenpolitisch denn die
Angehörigen den verbliebenen Geiseln
werden darauf drängen dass auch sie
freikommen danke schön für diese
Informationen aus Tel Aviv Michael
Bunge der Krieg in narost verändert auch
die Sicherheitslage in Deutschland so
warnt unter anderem der
Verfassungsschutz vor einer akuten
Gefahr islamistischer Anschläge in
Niedersachsen wurde ein 20-jähriger in
Gewahrsam genommen der Iraker soll
Anschläge auf Großveranstaltungen in der
Adventszeit geplant haben die Ermittler
schließen nicht aus dass der
Weihnachtsmarkt in Hannover ein
mögliches Ziel gewesen sein
könnte nach Berlin und z Diskussion über
den
Nachtragshaushalt der Bundestag hat
heute dazu in erster Lesung debattiert
nach dem Urteil aus Karlsruhe Fehlen der
Regierung Milliarden die Schuldenbremse
fürs laufende Jahr soll ausgesetzt
werden für das kommende Jahr will
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner daran
festhalten noch mehr Schulden bei stark
gestiegenen Zinsen sei nicht der
richtige Weg so Lindner von SPD und
Grünen kommen dagegen Forderungen auch
im kommenden Jahr die Schuldenbremse
auszusetzen
mehr Einnahmen in Zeiten knapper Kassen
soll die zusätzliche lkwmaut bringen ab
heute müssen schwere Diesel LKW einen
Aufschlag für CO2 Abgase zahlen das soll
dem Staat pro Jahr fast 8 Milliarden
Euro bescheren und die Unternehmen zum
Umstieg auf klimafreundlichere LKW
bewegen aber nicht nur Spediteure sind
skeptisch und warnen vor steigenden
Preisen für die Verbraucher Oliver
deuker hart kalkulieren musste
Transportunternehmer Böhm schon immer
die Marge also der Gewinn pro Auftrag
ist in seiner Branche gering ab heute
muss der Seniorchef pro Tonne CO2
aussturz 200 € auf die lkwmaut
drauflegen wir rechnen mit über 2
Millionen pro
Jahr bei unseren 100 LKWs hier auf der
Straße sind dann und diese 2 Millionen
müssen ja können wir nicht kompensieren
die müssen weitergereicht werden und das
wird schlussendlich der Endverbraucher
der Bürger zahlen müssen B Kunden
übernehmen also die Mehrkosten das ist
aber nicht bei allen
Transportunternehmern so wir vermuten
eine hohe Anzahl von Insolvenzen weil
gerade auch die leerrkilometer von den
Auftraggebern nicht vollendst übernommen
werden können und das bedeutet dass
gerade unser Gewerbe welches in den
letzten Jahren schon
sehr belastet worden ist noch mehr
belastet wird mit dem in Brüssel
beschlossenen CO2 Aufschlag hofft die
Ampelkoalition in Berlin den Umstieg auf
klimaneutrale Antriebe zu beschleunigen
Fachleute sind skeptisch geht's nur um
die Einnahmen oder geht's wirklich um
das Klima weil ein Klimaeffekt den sehe
ich an der Stelle erstmal nicht es
werden so schnell und in den nächsten
Jahren überhaupt keine äh Fahrzeuge die
elektrisch betrieben werden und dann die
Maut eben auch nicht zahlen müssen
verfügbar sein der CO2 Aufschlag wird
europaweit zeitlich und auch in der Höhe
unterschiedlich gehandhabt die
mehereinnahmen hierzulande von etwa 7,6
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr sollen dem
Ausbau der Bahn zugute kommen
die Arbeit in der Altenpflege
attraktiver machen mit diesem Ziel
steigen dort ab heute die Mindestlöhne
und zwar je nach Qualifikation auf 14,15
€ bis 18,25
pro Stunde im Mai nächsten Jahres dann
auf 15,50 € bis 19,50 € die Kehrseite
auf Pflegebedürftige kommen damit höhere
Kosten
zu heute ist Weltaidstag vor gut 40
Jahren verändert die Immunschwäche
Krankheit die Welt viele auch junge
Menschen starben die Angst sich
anzustecken war immens damals in den
1980ern stieg die Zahl der
Neuinfektionen in Deutschland massiv an
und noch mal Anfang der 2000er derzeit
infizieren sich hier zu Lande noch immer
etwa 1800 Menschen pro Jahr weltweit
sind es rund 1,5 Millionen Morin ilau
über einen Mann der seit Jahrzehnten mit
AIDS lebt erst fühlte es sich so an als
hätte er eine Grippe Georg Berner
weindock ist damals 17 Jahre alt als er
die Diagnose bekommt HIV positiv ein
Schock für den Homosexuellen aus
Niedersachsen sein Arzt gibt ihm maximal
noch ein Jahr zu leben ja ich habe
gedacht jetzt ist alles vorbei und jetzt
du brauchst eigentlich nichts mehr zu
machen also weder Schule zu Ende noch
Ausbildung noch sonstiges weil die
Prognosen waren ja auch sehr sehr
niedrig
Überlebenschancen in seinem
Freundeskreis beginnt sterben Berner
weindock geht von einer Beerdigung zur
nächsten die Diagnose HIV in den 80er
Jahren fast ein Todesurteil das Virus
zerstört das Immunsystem es kommt z
Hysterie betroffene leiden neben der
Krankheit an Ausgrenzung
1996 gelingt der medizinische Durchbruch
eine Therapie kann die Zahl der Viren
eindämmen AIDS bricht dadurch nicht aus
Menschen mit HIV können heute
medizinisch wirklich gut leben und tun
das in der Regel auch zumindest wenn
rechtzeitig diagnostiziert und behandelt
wird aber Diskriminierung und Vorurteile
machen den Menschen das Leben dann
wieder schwer besonders schwer neben der
Ausgrenzung war es für Georg Berner
weindock früher so viele Tabletten
einnehmen zu müssen mehr als 60 am Tag
mit vielen Nebenwirkungen heute reichen
zwei das Gefühl ist dass ich froh bin
dass die HIV Infektion zurückgehen dass
ist so gute Medikamente gibt dass ich
einfach heutzutage als chronisch krank
gelte ja das ist einfach ist eine
leichterung Aids hat seinen Schrecken
verloren ist aber immer noch eine
unheilbare
Krankheit das ist der Blick von der
Zugspitze an einem perfekten skifahrtag
leider sah das heute nicht ganz so aus
ohnehin ist die Stimmung zur neuen
Skisaison durchwachsen nicht nur der
Klimawandel belastet die Skigebiete
offenbar lässt auch die Lust am
Skifahren nach von Deutschlands höchsten
Berg berichtet Claudia
Vogelmann tief verschneit präsentiert
sich die Zugspitze doch die idyle trügt
der schwindene Gletscher lässt aus
hängen senken werden nimmt diesem
liftball die Unterlage er ist angezählt
doch auf Deutschlands höchsten Berg hält
man noch am Skibetrieb fest wer nah an
den Bergen wohnt schickt seine Kinder
eigentlich früh auf die Piste Michi
Brunner litet eine Skischule am Hausberg
und registriert jetzt aber dass immer
weniger Kinder die hier wohnen auch
Skifahren
können mer ist oft an Skikurse für die
Schulen das einind Drittel der ja
fünfklässer teilweise noch nie auf Ski
gestanden sind noch nie wurde es so
kontrovers darüber diskutiert ob skifah
noch in die Zeit passt in tieferen Lagen
ist vielorts künstlicher Schnee der
Garant für den Skibetrieb Schneekanonen
und Lanzen werden zwar
energieeffizienter benötigen aber immer
noch Wasser und Strom der
winterschiourismus ist im todgeweiht und
es ist nicht zeitgemäß da dran
festzuhalten und da weiter zu
investieren garmischparten Kirchen ist
ein ganzjahresurlaubsgebiet 40% aller
Gäste kommen im Winter der Wintersport
ist ein wesentlicher
Wirtschaftsfaktor solange der Winter und
der Schnee zu uns kommt gibt es gar
keine Veranlassung von Wintertourismus
generell Abstand demm zu wollen hier
plant man schon für die Zeit mit wenig
Schnee zu wichtig ist die Saison über
6000 Arbeitsplätze garantiert der
Tourismus Schnee hin oder
her im schwedischen ö und beim Biathlon
Weltcup gibt's reichlich Schnee aber
heute keinen deutschen Podestplatz ja
aber dennoch ein erfolgreicher Tag beim
Sprint der Frauen reichte es für
Franziska Preu heute zwar nur für den
vierten Platz sie hat aber als erste
deutsche seit mehr als sechseinhalb
Jahren das Gelbe Trikot der
Gesamtführenden
erobert dieser verflixte letzte Schuss
ist auch im Ziel das beherrschende Thema
bei Franziska Pre einfach ärgerlich beim
letzten Schießen geht der letzte Schuss
dann
das war immer so blöd der letzte Schuss
das ja was man immer Predigt das ganze
Jahr drauf halten und ja ich war dann
vielleicht ein Ticken zu ungeduldig am
schiand und ja aber trotzdem war ein
gutes Rennen s zehnel fehlen am Ende zu
Platz 3 dennoch erfreulich am Sonntag
trägt preus das Gelbe Trikot gemeinsam
mit der punktleichen Norwegerin Knotten
die französinis feiert ihren ersten
weltcupsiegess fre sich über
Rang die DFB Frauen spielen gleich in
der nations League gegen Dänemark und
müssen unbedingt gewinnen um die Chance
auf den Gruppensieg und die Olympia
Qualifikation zu wahren ja Sven Foss
sozusagen Showdown in
Rostock hast du mich
s leg
los wirorem kalter Showdown -7° hier im
Ostseestadion von Rostock und ja ich
höre dich sehr gut wenn du mich auch
hörst dann rede ich auch weiter ja also
-7° hier es wird ein eiskalter Showdown
hier im Ostseestadion von Rostock die
deutschen Frauen müssen gewinnen am
besten hoch und im Team von Horst
rubesch ist vor allem die Kapitänin
Alexandra Pop dafür zuständig dass das
klappt mit einem Sieg gegen Dänemark
damit der Traum von Olympia weiterleben
kann das Ganze ab 20:15 Uhr hier im
ZDF danke s wir sehen uns gleich wieder
und die deutschen Handballfrauen die
sind gestern Abend mit einem
harterkämpften Sieg erfolgreich in die
WM gestartet gegen Japan stand es wenige
Sekunden vor Spielende Unentschieden
dann traf Xenia smitz unmittelbar vor
der Schlusssirene zum 31 Z3 Happy End
aus deutscher Sicht im dänischen
Herning ja morgen Abend das zweite
Gruppenspiel gegen Iran danke schön zum
Schluss noch eine kleine Geschichte die
sie ermutigen könnte mal wieder auf dem
Dachboden oder im Keller zu kramen
vielleicht finden sie einen Schatz so
geschehen jetzt in Italien in einem
Privathaus tauchte nicht irgendein
Ölschinken auf sondern ein Bild vom
renaissancemaler BTY Chelly 50 Jahre
lang war es verschollen geschätzter Wert
100 Millionen Euro in Zukunft soll die
Madonna mit Kind öffentlich ausgestellt
werden der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt
vor stark Schneefall im Süden Bayerns
die Details zum Wetter hat gleich
Christa Orben das heute journal mit
Christian siers in der Halbzeitpause um
9:4 uh und wir sind morgen wieder da
ihnen noch einen schönen Abend und alles
Gute auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend der will es an
diesem 1 Dezembertag Wissen im Süden des
Landes schneite es den ganzen Tag und es
hört bis morgen Abend nicht auf zwischen
dem Alge und der unteren Donau können 30
bis 40 cm Schnee fallen das bedeutet
Unwettergefahr rechnen sie mit
erheblichen Behinderungen im Straßen und
Schienenverkehr zwischen dem Bodensee
und dem Bayerischen Wald fallen 10 bis
30 zwischen dem Schwarzwald und dem
Erzgebirge 5 bis 10 cm Neuschnee
übrigens können auch in den
Schneeschauern an den Küsten heute Nacht
und morgen um 5 cm dabei sein wo es
auflockert sinken die Temperaturen auch
über Schnee auf -10° das ist durchweg
frostig heute Nacht auch frostig ist der
morgige Samstag bei meist -5 bis 0° nur
an den Küsten sind + 2° möglich das
liegt hier am noch relativ warmen Wasser
und das ist in Kombination mit diesem
trocken kalten Wind aus Norden auch der
Grund für die Schneeschauer hier die
morgen bis zur Mitte ausgreifen können
der starke Schneefall im Süden lässt
nachmittags von Westen her etwas nach
aber im Südosten Bayern schneit es bis
zum Abend ganz anders sieht aber der
erste Adventssonntag aus da bringt ein
Zwischenhoch knackig kaltes aber ruhiges
Wetter das nächste Schnee und regentief
mit glatten Straßen kommt am Montag und
am Dienstag tschüss